I wonder if you know because we're
recording this the week of right
but I wonder if the week of what uh
somewhere near here yeah yeah February
I wonder if January so I'm really gonna
try to gun
well uh what sorry
you gotta finish that one
gun down
a bunch of troubles okay
this season I'm really looking for yeah
truffle hunting yeah uh late late last
year I was really gunning to try to pack
some weight on okay because you know
last year I was pussyfooting about it so
late last year I was gonna gun for it so
I wonder if by the time this comes out
will there just be a minor shrinkage in
my appearance shrinkage oh like this
episode like almost like it's like yeah
yeah
you know just like like you're jacked
and then someone's like someone free
transform yeah no well for this episode
I don't think it's possible for me to be
jacked without roids right but I think
it'll just be like Mario losing the
mushroom then gaining it back kind of
thing so my editor does he he did that
last video he like made me small and
then he I laughed pretty much yeah it's
really funny yeah he's been starting my
videos like that yesterday was like
I like screamed or something to start
the video and so he did like the
fortnite Emoji or fortnite like emote oh
nice animation and chose scream and then
I screamed nice funny yeah bro I I miss
on stream whenever I play games
uh story based games you know
and
anytime I killed an innocent person I
would just hit the victory Royale
[Laughter]
all right on stream yeah that's right
yeah I overlaid it there
I forgot about that you had that on your
stream that was always really funny
there was one where I played this game
where it was like a horror game and
there was everyone in a house and I
flicked a switch and I tricked like a
triggered a gas line and killed everyone
in the house
oh you know you know what it was I
played some game where you you have the
option to kill a dog oh I shot the dog
lucky
oh and then you did the victory Royale
just that sound just
so [__] but God damn it had me crying
yeah yeah
that's [__] good I should have did
that yeah I should have did yeah
over this like
dog corpse yeah like dude this is [__]
up man yeah
you can't see it now we're emoting on
the dead dog
that's messed up man shouldn't be
laughing at that yeah that's [__] up I
think I was just more caught up in
laughing at the fact that I triggered it
yeah
yeah just watching I was too caught up
watching the chat no
no people are having like you know a
really good time watching your stream
man I love Noel he's so funny
oh oh my god oh man I'm sad now Victory
Royale dude
man I think I might start again when I
get back from tour killing dogs yeah
kicking them
dog kicking stream yo we're doing a dog
kicking stream this Friday
I'm here at the dog adoption center and
we're gonna start kicking them oh damn
that actually goes down a dark road yeah
why what road are you thinking oh cause
you know there's plenty of dog there's
like kill shelters I know yeah it's sad
yeah
I think yeah anyways I think it starts
streaming
on Twitch not on Twitch yeah it's
probably YouTube yeah I don't know I
mean your Twitch still you got like do
you still have subscribers yes yeah like
yeah dude I tell them I say cancel it
they're like nah I still subscribe to
Sam they're like pretty sure I think me
and Marcus are the only ones and every
month I get that [__] like push
notification it says you've been charged
4.99 or whatever for Sam shots use it
like I'm [__] I'm buying this guy's
coffee once a month he doesn't do [__]
because twitch takes half
yes I'm buying his
half of a coffee
he doesn't do [__] yeah
I'm just waiting for when he gets you
know back on which is never
I loved his Who Wants To Be A
Millionaire stream I thought that was so
funny
what did he do he played the PC game Who
Wants To Be A Millionaire that's sick
and he wore like a green screen suit he
like went yeah he like went all out yeah
really I think I'm pretty sure yeah it
was hilarious never seen him put that
much effort I just I couldn't believe it
I'm like wow he's trying
I'm like dang this is genius and then
nothing after that I'm like what is he
doing oh so you see how many people
stripe just laid off um I know the most
valuable private company yeah in the
world right now one of them yeah and
they just laid off like 15 of their
it's [__] crazy I picked a really
good time to get back in a stand-up why
because people are sad everyone's laid
off I mean it's kind of but that's kind
of true
that should be a good time to be it you
think people want to laugh yeah Fair
yeah I mean they might not have as much
money for a ticket but
I'm serious like I I I'm like the next
year that like entertainment you know
people's entertainment budget are
probably gonna dry up a little bit you
know what's crazy I was talking to my
dad about this and his dad lived through
the Great Depression
and his dad said to him
it was actually the inverse he said
during the Great Depression people
always managed to
like scribe money together for
entertainment yeah
yep that's really interesting which I
was like maybe you know what's kind of
interesting what I've been thinking
about I mean I mean maybe this is a
little bit depressing or whatever maybe
it's not that relevant when this episode
comes out but
it is kind of
I mean I don't know we're in a pretty
like fortunate you know blessed position
where we're making stuff that we like to
do and making money doing it right yeah
so
I just it just feels weird that now
we're seeing people like so many
advertisers cancel ads
right before the holidays which should
be like the hottest most you know the
the period of time where they spend the
most on advertisements and now like
having my close friends get laid off and
stuff that's like
just seeing the effects of the economy
before
it really is like official that we're in
a recession yeah it's just crazy it's
eye-opening you know scary yeah scary
stuff
but um
yeah I don't know we can cut that all
apart
[Music]
anyway yeah streaming yeah yeah so what
are you gonna do
um I don't know I think
I'm just not sure I kind of wanna
convert the garage
into this sort of you know I don't know
Mega streaming
thing media yeah like or just a just
like a media workshop thing you know
yeah if you want to build a stool in
there I can yeah if I want to weld some
pipe and yeah yeah build a go-kart you
should definitely do that
I think that's the move when I get back
that's a great idea I I there's one
project I want to do everyone's done it
but I just want to do it my version or
just not my version but just I want to
do it myself which is buying the Harbor
Freight go-kart engine and building a
okay a go-kart it's from scratch how
much is that engine
uh it's got 212 CC's so I think it can
go up to like 50 miles an hour no matter
how expensive that's like three four
hundred bucks for the engine yeah
and then you you have to like buy the
parts and you know can you can you
fabricate like anything around it you
could yeah 100 that's kind of cool yeah
so I think it'd be funny people what
would you do
uh I'd I'd want to build something
ridiculous you know I'd want to build a
frame and then Fab something around it
that looks so [__] dumb and super
funny you know
you should build a a sideways car yeah
like build a go-kart that's sideways I
think goes this way
the wheels are yeah
no the wheel you can't see the wheels
yes but it's like the real ones but you
can you can put some Wheels on the
outside that don't actually touch the
ground and it totally looks like like
it's moving yeah it's I'm gonna good
idea I'm gonna be uh easy to parallel
park yeah I'm gonna be the king of
um non-aerodynamic cars
because after the hot laps car that's a
square front and then a sideways car is
a square front
see that's the real test of driving dude
it's not [__]
what it's not having like a car that's
meant for driving it's about having one
that's really hard to drive exactly
seeing if you can hang yeah test your
skills make a backwards car yeah
someone's done that oh that's funny dude
there's a really funny there's another
guy oh [__] I wish I remember the
YouTuber's name basically he got a
parking Park Rover no but it's like Mark
Rover but funny okay so this dude got a
ticket for uh parking somewhere where
you have to uh you have to park head in
only okay and he reversed in okay so he
chopped a Honda Civic
and he built it so it was both sides
were the front
and he parked it and then the dude was
about to get taken he runs like hey whoa
the guy's like oh
I guess
I can't just add it I love [__] like
yeah